all right roy yes roy where did you grow
up where are you from originally
abington
in the suburbs of philly in pennsylvania
and tell me about your family you had
mom and dad
yeah uh i never met my real father
i was adopted by
my stepfather when i was
six
and um i've had my mom and my
grandparents
very small family
how would you describe your childhood in
general
typical 80s kid
70s and 80s kid
um you know come home before the lights
were your street lights on
were you born 1971 i'm 50.
and uh
i didn't have a very big family growing
up
um i only had a few very slick fam like
pretty much just my mom growing up with
and
my mom
were you an only child yeah
a lot of abusive relationships with my
mom ex-boyfriends
but
thank god my stepfather adopted me never
never abused me or never
nothing ever happened to you no not not
family
not family
in the family thank god outside the
family
yeah i was abused i was
i was i was molested
i was raped by um
some people that that lived down the
street that i was friends with i guess
they're
their nephew
wait how old were you i was um
seven or eight
seven years old eight years old
we were
back then we ran around the streets you
know it was
it was
it was safe right
it
you know it was in the 80s it was it was
a different time we were allowed to run
around the streets and
as long as we came home
we were supposed to everything was fine
it was a different
different time yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
uh
very misunderstood
adhd not pain not paying attention not
really
you know not really getting in trouble
trouble just
not paying attention not doing my work
and i'm not able to apply yourself
towards school yeah i didn't i didn't
really try very hard adhd is a
hard thing for a lot of people yeah
yeah very much
they didn't have the medications they
have today and even if they did
it wouldn't have i don't know that it
would have worked
seeing my
outcome
becoming an adult
like i remember as a kid when i
remember having you know my when i had a
cold or whatever which was often because
i i remember liking
cough medicine when i was a kid
as young as like like seven years old
do you think that's just in your dna
i believe so i was
my mom was addicted to meth when i was
born
right
yeah and you got introduced to
harder drugs at what age
well besides like the cough medicine and
stuff like
early grade school
early grade school
not by choice of course
who turned you into that
a friend that actually died of a heroin
overdose in kensington
i remember a kid brian a very good
friend of mine when i was a child
i miss him dearly
and you've had you've had jobs of course
yeah i'm sorry yes yeah i first started
working when i was
14 or 15 on a farm believe it or not
it's not farmland around here either so
uh
working and he was
he was a little molester himself
bob moore i'm not afraid to say his name
i'm sure he's dead by now but
yeah it was a bad that was ugly too with
him
he was a
scumbag
he liked
little kids
that's what i grew up with
i'm not blame that's i don't think
that's an excuse for my drug addiction
but
it doesn't help no
i grew up with very bad
very bad night terrors
i i still don't dream today i don't
dream
i um
when i was a kid i remember waking up
having really bad night terrors to where
i didn't even know what the dreams were
about
i just remember waking up
crying my eyes out my parents
bear hugging me trying to get me to stop
running around the house
you know
i don't even know what the dreams were
about but that that led me to not even
having any more dreams
i'm petrified to dream
do you think it affects your quality of
sleep
yeah
big time dreaming yeah
i don't i haven't slept in like three
days now i don't
yeah i haven't slept in like really for
real three days like for real sleep me
what is your drug now my drug of choice
is heroin
heroin won't necessarily keep you awake
sure it does really yeah i have what the
i guess it's called the paradox effect i
don't really
i don't nod out from heroin really
unless you know is that because you're
adhd i don't know
i don't know i
i've never been able to get
a real
diagnosis and maybe like just help fix
[ __ ]
on with my life through doctors and
stuff i know my mom cared and everything
my parents cared but
i don't think they knew what to do
i remember having one
one good
psychiatrist dr scharf
so i remember having one good
child psychologist psychiatrist whatever
and uh
the only thing i really remember him is
him taking me to this
trailer park and saying that i don't
want to be like this
that's about how i really i remember
going to his office but that's about all
i remember with the therapy
so i never really got any kind of
a scared straight program
yeah not really yeah i guess didn't work
no
i'm not i don't i'm not scared like i
don't get scared walking around
kensington or
it doesn't i just don't
i don't get how long have you have you
been on kensington is it on kensington
in kensington
where they call it kensington beach
where we go now
two years old
yeah and how long has kenzi and kenzie
hasn't been around oh gosh like
like this
full of drug addicts and homeless people
since at least the 80s 90s you're you
remember it as a kid yeah yeah it wasn't
i was i wasn't drug addicts then it was
probably alcoholics no it's yeah mostly
alcoholics and um
glue huffers kind of stuff
when i was outside of high school just
out of high school
i uh i
tried to do something with myself and i
i became a guardian angel down in
philadelphia down here and kensington
and somerset
and uh
we didn't see i didn't see any i might
have heard about crack addicts you know
crackheads and stuff but
i've never seen there was never any
heroin addicts or anything like that it
was not
the way it is now yeah
nothing
frankfurt ave and
kensington have
um allegheny that was all a lot of
shopping
you know it was it was it's crazy the
way it's it's turned around it's changed
there's all the you know all the trash
in the attics
it's it's pretty it's pretty hardcore it
is very hardcore
yeah
lost souls just trying to find something
and yeah
and just trying to
numb whatever
things that we have going on inside do
you feel like that's what you're doing
absolutely yeah what you went through as
a kid
100 yeah
i yeah
even though your stepdad was a good good
guy it sounds like
he was a decent guy he
just because he didn't beat me and
molest me
you know he was a good guy no i
i love him
how was your relationship with your mom
uh she was my best friend
she was my rock she was the only thing
that kept me
i could
she was the only one that kept me
doing the right thing pretty much
i um
i miss her a lot i lost her not too long
ago in june
i'm sorry
apparently she knew that she had an
aorta dissection in her heart valve
aorta valve
but
decided not to tell me i
the only thing i could think of is so i
didn't
so i wasn't hurting so i wasn't upset
and scared and for her because we were
best friends my mom was my best friend
100
but in the long run she doesn't know but
not telling me and
me finding her dead in bed
june 27th was the worst thing that's
ever happened to me
i wouldn't
i wouldn't wish that on
the worst
person that i've ever met in my life
that even any kind of molester on me i i
wouldn't
wish that on anyone
to find their own mother in bed like
that dad i'm sorry
yeah
she was the only person that kept me in
line
if if i was in line
so
what does your day look like
here on in kensington
what do you do you wake up
or do you not wake up you just stay up
well i mean if i do sleep you know i
i'm on a lot of medication to sleep
and uh
you know i'm
i'm just trying to
get through the day pretty much
how do you make money uh i'm on i'm on
disability
and that's enough too
no
but it works i i i i make i make do i do
what i can
do you have friends
not many
i i i don't
i don't like having a lot of friends
well down here they're probably not very
trustworthy
well yeah of course not really you know
yeah down here or not not very
trustworthy
but even in general
i i always if i always had friends i
always had a very small circle because
uh when i do have good friends i feel i
feel like i need to be there for them
all the time and you can't do that if
you have
you know a whole bunch of people that
you have to
try and please on a daily you know on
the daily
yeah
you seem like a good-hearted person
i i
without
i i believe i am but to be here
in kensington where
there's lots of snakes and thieves and
hustlers and
very rough kind of person like me
it is i i'm not
being
what is that narcissistic or being like
high on myself or anything but you know
i know it's very hard to be down here
because i you have to you can't
i'm too nice for a lot of
for the whole for the this whole entire
thing this whole scene
let's hold the whole thing
it's a horrible ruthless
scene and you have to be that way
you don't have to hurt people and stuff
but you have to be rough around the
edges and i'm really
i have a hard time being rough around
the edges have you changed since you've
been down here yeah
yeah
i have in what ways
i've gotten a little bit more rough
around the edges and i don't like it
i don't i don't like having to like
i don't even like saying no to people if
they ask me for a cigarette or or
something i i hate it
i'm a people pleaser but you can't be
that way down here you'll get killed
you can't trust everybody that you run
into just because they're nice to you
the first time because you will get
killed and i'm
really surprised i haven't gotten killed
what's the worst thing that's happened
to you since you did here
um
when you're not even overdosing and
finding myself in a hospital um
um trying to find somebody to help
shoot me up so i can get better so i can
help my friend that was overdosing and
end up
being kidnapped and have a gun put to my
head in my face
that was probably the worst thing that's
ever happened to me down here
i just was trying to help my friend
they were driving my vehicle at the time
and i couldn't
i couldn't
i was having small
seizures kind of thing in my like these
brain zaps that i get in my head
and it was
affecting i couldn't get my friend
better so we can go to the hospital
to get him to the hospital
i never did
not sure what happened to him
uh it's not
i don't take that lightly i have to on
the outside but it's very hard on on the
inside
do you find
you you begin to normalize things that
are not really
yeah you should be normalizing yes
because and it scares me
there's a lot of really good people down
here but
there's a there's even more
people that are just out to
get whatever they can from you and
discard you
it's gotta it's got to be depressing to
be around that yeah
and it's yeah
it's hard to hold that in but i do
i do what i can
what are you afraid of no what do you
worry about
i'm afraid of my daughter
i'm afraid
i don't want my daughter to see me like
this down here ever
i don't
have any more fat i have no more family
i only have a
29 year old daughter i have no other
family
i don't have one other family member
that's
half family members like aunt and cousin
but i don't even talk to them i don't
have any other blood family no blood
relatives at all
so i don't really have anybody else to
get help from
or
or even
talk to
as a family member
it sucks
yeah
what do you think most people don't
understand about addiction drug
addiction
i said it's not something you can just
quit exactly
my drug of choice being heroin
it's
heroin now fentanyl
yeah that's exactly right there is no
more heroin it's just easier to call it
that yeah it's a hunt it's fentanyl and
um
mostly xylamine this is a tranquilizer
animal animal tranquilizer yeah it's
like it's like for horses
i believe no not necessarily for her i
don't think it's for horses i think it's
for larger animals yeah yeah
yeah
it's
there's the methadone the suboxone the
subutex and all that stuff doesn't work
for that stuff
it doesn't work
i started on pain medication when i hurt
my back and knees it was that was
and i
i i didn't do heroin till i was 40 years
old
i was on you know i was on maintenance
medication for a long time
and then i did heroin because i couldn't
i couldn't
get back to normal uh
once i found and got addicted to opiates
that was the end
that was the end it's
to me it's a miracle drug that
with the right circumstances if like if
it wasn't money issues i'd be a very
productive person
i'd be a very productive member of
society i find i
wholeheartedly believe that it does not
cause problems in my in my life just the
the negative
[ __ ] that people see about it and
the negative [ __ ] it does in one's life
like takes all the money away and stuff
they said look if it was a prescribed
medicine i would be that would be the
medication for me that would
make me
a very good person you believe it helps
you
yeah
yes
but
so why are you in the situation you're
in
because it takes money away because it
it because of the bad the negatives
the negative
stigma
the negative outlooks it gives people
and
what everybody thinks of it
being addicted to opiates
heroin whatever that you know
recently it just became the whole
fentanyl thing right yeah it's only been
a few years yeah i'm not really crazy
about that i would much rather have
heroin
you know
it's the fentanyl it's
yeah
yeah once once person
gets addicted to fentanyl it just seems
like it's it's a whole new game oh big
time yeah yeah because
one thing because they don't have any
kind of maintenance medication to get
people
off of it and
you know just to change their
their
their actions and and
you know to get to better their life
because it it causes such [ __ ] and
and [ __ ] chaos in people's lives
this is so hard to get
but when it's such a when it does such
good things for some people
or or does it really do good things i
don't know i mean in
in my in my brain i feel as though it
does
i don't steal i wouldn't steal for it i
wouldn't rob people for it
it's just you know i don't do that stuff
that are you so you still have a moral
compass that's intact yeah but most
people on fentanyl
and being 50 years old have a hard time
with that
yeah i'm not i can't change that i've
seen female addicts who seem to have
their lives together
except
they're homeless and they're
they're scrounging from day to day to
but yeah get their fix yeah
i mean they're not robbing and stealing
from everybody right no i wouldn't rob
somebody or no nobody
i wouldn't be afraid to admit it if i
were before either
i have no problem huh but what was your
favorite memory in your life
my favorite memory the best memory
i have to say my daughter was born i
know that's probably uh
typical but no it really is i think it
is
yeah my daughter being boy i don't
remember ever being as happy as i was
do you talk to her talk to her now
absolutely you do yeah
she's all i have left
i don't know what i would do without her
if she happens to see this video
what will that do to your relationship
with her absolutely nothing yeah i'm an
open book she knows all this she knows
everything
yeah yeah yeah my mom yeah
i don't i don't lie like that either
i've never
my mom didn't have to catch me doing
drugs i would tell i told her but she
could tell it's a great way to be
that's a great way for you to be yeah
it's very it's liberating because i
don't have to worry about remembering
it's easier to heal too yeah once all
your stuff is on the table yeah and i
keep it on the table especially with my
family you know close friends so they're
easier for you to make a change one day
yeah i believe people can make a change
one day absolutely they just have to
have the right
circumstances and time the right mindset
yeah everything yeah somebody who says
somebody who just doesn't make a change
doesn't make a change doesn't make a
change doesn't mean that one day they
won't right no that's and it's never too
late to change either yeah
miracles do happen
yeah i'm waiting
i'm waiting for the miracle i don't know
when you drive down
kensington and see all the people that
are just like lost and gone
it seems like there's no hope for them
but there is there is absolutely every
single person
absolutely
i don't care what they're doing wrong
there's always a hope for everybody yeah
even like
even the people that's wronged me the
most in my life
i'm not that kind of person who holds
grudges like
you know
i i believe everybody deserves another
chance and sometimes three four chances
it depends but yeah
everybody's got something good inside
them somewhere
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
well
without going crazy about it
i think
i'm trying to do better
and i guess
trying to better my like
trying to do better in school that way i
would have more discipline growing up
so i can
like i started i got somewhere in life
but then i i got lost getting there yeah
but you're punishing yourself for being
adhd
in some ways right yeah
yeah i could never sit down and just
read
an entire paragraph so they said i was
being bad
because i couldn't remember the first
[ __ ] sentence when i'm
four or five sentences deep in a book
i've never read an entire book all the
way through i'm not stupid at all
but i can't keep track of it
there was no audio books when i was a
kid yeah
it must have been hard you just put me
in they just put me in the special
education classes
and and forgot about it must have been
hard to grow up at a time when people
didn't even know yeah there was no adhd
you were just stupid yeah
yeah i was called stupid by well
from teachers yeah
i remember that but then you didn't go
home and there was no suing your
teachers or
i didn't run home and tell all my
teachers
i felt like that was my okay
it's how they think of me
right
i guess that's who i am not you know i
tell me whatever
but i i don't think that now
i guess you have other strengths i've
learned yeah you know people that are
adhd have other strengths they're just
not conventional
strengths that will get you through
school with good grades and yep i saw
this thing one about uh somebody with
the worst adhd let's say they're they
play online games they could sit there
and focus on
one game
for eight hours straight not even look
away
but they can't sit down and write it
a paper and that's me
i walked out on a ged class because i
didn't want to i couldn't do the
the
the big paper where um
we write a whole bunch of stuff about
just a certain subject
um the essay or whatever
this is a 500 word essay and i
walked out on it because i i
was too embarrassed and i i couldn't do
it i felt like i couldn't do it
you know i got my ged ended up but
i was by the skin of my teeth and from
jail
it's a shame because
they do have other strengths that are
there
just need to be brought out and used in
the right way i understood
i think a lot of adhd people were just
never understood so
yeah especially especially when i was
younger because it didn't even really
they just called me hyperactivity
hyperactive i had hyperactivity
and i was on this feingold diet where i
couldn't have red dyes i couldn't have
um
like i could only have like breyer's ice
cream reese's peanut butter like weird
stuff
and it didn't do a [ __ ] thing didn't
do a damn thing
i don't
i don't know
what happened from then until now
how i mean i do but i mean i don't
understand how
they've figured out so much that maybe
this stuff maybe they did know about it
but i'm on the east coast where the west
coast was doing all this
you know everything came out first over
there and i came here
i don't know
but i wish they would have
figured out more stuff when i was a
child when i was a kid
a little [ __ ] running around
rory what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
in 50 years
wow
well i i would say that
to give to always
to never go to sleep mad
to never go to sleep mad at anybody
anybody that you care about
even
especially you know if you know that
you're
it's gonna go you're going to develop a
relationship or friendship
it's just not there yet
to never go to sleep mad it's a great
one
because you don't you never know
you never know when they're not going to
wake up
the best thing that i've ever done
really actually was the last thing i
said to my mom was
i'll see you tomorrow i love you
before i went out
and
that's yeah that's
that's my answer to the best
the the thing that i've done in in life
that
the happiest thing i i guess you could
say because
me and my mom had a rough growing up she
was an alcoholic and stuff
so we had a lot of arguments because she
was
very argumentative when she was drunk
but
we weren't arguing then and that
i couldn't be
uh
thank
i'm just very thankful that we weren't
arguing then
about some stupid her being drunk
you know i miss her so much my mom
my life has fallen apart since june bed
yeah
so i don't know what to do without her
i really don't
she spoiled the [ __ ] out of me because
she felt like that was her job that's
the only thing she that's the best thing
that she could do for me
was to spoil me but it was the worst
thing
because i don't know what to [ __ ] do
without her
i don't know how to do stuff i don't
know how to live life
all right roy thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're welcome thank you i hope you uh i
hope you turn the corner and figure it
out yeah i hope so too sometimes it
takes time to heal that stuff yeah
yeah that's why you're i really haven't
grieved that much that well
i will
thank you very much
you